And now to you, Scoutmaster.
Hey, you're still there. huh,
Remember me
How you doing. This is podcast number 352..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Greene. It's been a busy summer on many fronts and I'm going to devote the entirety of this podcast to catching up,
Because it's not summer anymore, is it?
I want to talk through a few issues and events and then we'll talk about what's been going on at scoutmastercgcom and where we go from here.
I had a great trip to Kondersteg International Scout Center in Switzerland.
The troop had a great week at summer camp and they've laid the foundations for a great year of activities for our scouts.
The BSA began a listening campaign around the idea of quote serving the whole family, unquote, which is basically allowing girls to register in all of our age divisions.
There was a national jamboree where somebody spoke and there was an issue,
And I'm going to touch very briefly on all of those things, but first we took 22 people to Kondersteg International Scout Center in the village of Kondersteg, Switzerland, this summer.
We had a lovely time. If you have been a long time listener, you know that we do this as a high adventure trip every third summer
And I've talked at length about those trips in the past and you can find stuff online.
I did a set of videos about them on our last trip- not this year's trip, but on our last trip. that kind of give you an idea of what we do.
It's just a great activity. It's a great place to go. You get to meet scouts from all over the world.
You get to be in this world-class area of Switzerland. It's an amazing, amazing trip.
It was great fun. I did not get down to summer camp with the troop this year.
If you're following my own personal scouting career, I did retire as our scout master three years ago.
I came back to fill in over the 2016 and 2017 school year and I was happily able to retire a second time without quite so much fanfare,
because the troop has another new scout master now and that's going extraordinarily well.
So I'm not quite as involved in the day-to-day, week-to-week operations of the troop and the venture crew as I once was,
and I'm happy to see other people stepping up and taking it over and making it work.
Now, whether you know about it or not, the BSA started this kind of listening campaign over the summer
where they're talking about the issue of serving the whole family,
And I know that very specifically they're talking about whether or not to open our membership across all of our age divisions to girls,
And I'm very happy to hear at least we're discussing this. so let me weigh in on a few things.
When I go visit Condorsteg, we're there with- oh, somewhere between three and four hundred scouts from all over Europe
and other parts of the world for that week.
The norm is in the rest of the world, scouting organizations are co-eds,
So they have girls and boys in scout troops together, believe it or not,
And it works. It works really well. It's not all that mysterious or difficult. It's great.
I've had the honor of speaking with scouts from all over the world.
You've heard some of them interviewed on the podcast and I can tell you that, in my opinion,
this step by the BSA is not only going to make scouting better here in the United States.
it's going to be much easier and much better than anybody can really imagine.
It's going to be great.
I'm going to talk at a little more length about four things about this,
because you run into four objections or issues about this whenever it comes up.
First, I've heard some talk about the social and emotional development differences in boys and girls.
I believe that's a thing I understand, that. I think that's demonstrable.
But where I think we're getting it wrong is I've heard some people say
if we're going to offer membership to girls across all of our programs,
we're going to have to take this developmental difference into account
and guarantee a level playing field for the boys,
who some believe generally develop emotionally and socially slower than girls.
In short, I've heard the assertion that girls would just take all of the leadership positions
and leave the boys out in the cold.
I don't think there's a whole lot of merit to the argument
because right now we're serving boys of differing levels of ability and development.
We don't presently allocate opportunity according to those differences. right
To do so with girls doesn't make any sense to me.
It would be inherently sexist. It would fail miserably.
I just think it's a bad way to move forward
When this happens. a scout is a scout.
There you go Full stop
Now. second, there will be arguments against this based on the idea
that boys have to have some exclusive male atmosphere
away from girls and women to develop as men.
This was the same argument I heard when women were first permitted
to become scoutmasters 30 years ago.
It wasn't true then, It's not true now.
If boys can only develop into the right kind of men
because they are allotted some time in all male bastions,
away from feminine influences,
then I think we have to seriously question
the kind of men we want them to become
and the idea of manhood or masculinity that advances.
Third, there's going to be an argument that while the rest of the world
is scouting and co-ed, the transition that other programs had
from single sex to co-ed was fraught with huge losses in membership,
a lot of disruption in the scouting organizations.
Talking with youth-facing volunteers like you and I,
scouters who are in troops and packs and crews in the rest of the world
who were around for these transitions,
I think maybe that's partially true, and only partially.
But let's be real about the BSA
because nationally we haven't seen a positive growth year in two decades
so far as I know.
It's become increasingly difficult to find national membership numbers.
The BSA has always been a little recalcitrant
about publishing those numbers-
but that we haven't seen a positive growth year in a couple of decades nationally
I know there's been local areas of growth where membership grows,
but I'm talking on a national basis.
My best guess is two decades because you know what,
If we had a year where our national membership grew
in the past couple of decades, we would certainly hear about it.
Now there's a lot of reasons why this is happening.
There's not a single reason
In the context of what we're talking about today.
we're talking about being a co-ed organization,
and is the fact that we're presently a single-sex organization
and most of our programs a factor in our limited membership growth
or our membership decline?
I think it is. I mean, it only makes sense, right,
If you make the program available to more children,
you can have more members, at least potentially.
But when it comes down to it, this decision should not solely be a question
of metrics and memberships
and whether or not it's going to make some people uncomfortable.
It should be a question of what's the right thing to do.
And let's remember: organizations are just organizations.
They are not scouting.
Scouting started without them.
Scouting will move on without them, if need be.
Organizations are great advanceers and containers of scouting,
great enablers of scouting,
provide opportunities for young people to be scouts,
But scouting is.
But organizational disruption is not going to kill scouting,
Never has, never will.
Fourth and finally, there's going to be an argument
that other societies and cultures are simply better suited to this change,
while ours is not.
Now, if you think about this,
you're really not aware of what's going on,
because I have welcomed the incredibly positive
and affirmative changes
that our society and culture has made
over the past decade or more
when it comes to gender, when it comes to sexual orientation.
Those changes are going to keep going
and our young people are way, way past us,
especially past our organization, on these issues,
And it's been way too long since we have tried to catch up.
Certainly, there's going to be a lot of discussion
and there's going to be some controversy as this happens,
But as far as I'm concerned, who ray for co-ed scouting?
It can't happen soon enough.
It should be implemented at the organizational level
as simply and as quickly as possible,
because it's going to mean a lot.
It's going to make the program better for our boys
and it's going to mean a lot for our girls.
I also think it's worth considering for a moment
the kind of severe political and cultural unrest
that we've seen this year in the division
that we've experienced as a country,
because it was highlighted in the world of scouting
during the national jamboree with the president's speech.
I'm not going to opine about the content of the speech,
the reactions to it or anything like that.
Let's just use that as a touch point
to talk about the broader issue,
because when this kind of thing happens,
when we're experiencing this kind of division and unrest,
young people we serve are going to be looking for answers
and trying to sort things out
and, no doubt, expressing their personal opinions
on recent events.
So what is a scouter's role
dealing with these kinds of issues?
Well, it's not to advance our personal political,
religious or social position,
but to help the young people we serve
sort these things out for themselves.
We're fortunate to have some very powerful tools
to do just that,
and those tools are the scout oath and law.
If we're wise,
rather than expressing our own personal political opinions
or social opinions or religious opinions,
we will use the scout oath and law wisely
to help young people sort out on their own
what they are thinking and feeling about things.
If we wield these tools deftly and skillfully,
we can accomplish this without espousing
a particular political, religious or cultural position.
If and when you end up in a discussion
with the youth that you serve
about issues like this,
honor the commitment that you've made as a scouter
by focusing on using the oath and law
to define these events,
rather than trying to promulgate your own personal point of view,
your own politics,
your own take on a social issue.
So here are three things to remember to make that work.
Don't make statements as much as ask questions.
If you're confronted with discussions of things like this,
don't make statements about them.
Ask questions of the young people.
find out how they understand them.
The second thing to do is to make sure you listen
to those answers.
I am one of those people who are guilty of forming
what I am going to say
in answer to a question
as the question is being asked,
and I kind of forget to listen sometimes.
And third, lay aside your own opinions and ideas,
become a neutral observer
and explore what your scouts are thinking and feeling.
Doing those three things focuses on what we're charged with
and what we promise to do as scouts,
and that is enable our scouts to develop character
through the scout oath and law,
and not to promote a particular point of view
or a specific way of seeing the world,
Because when we have political unrest,
when we have divisiveness,
we're not only going to be calmed by people of goodwill
who strive for ideals that we can all hold in common:
The ideals of the scout. oath and law
have this nearly universal appeal
that overcomes divisions,
and if we apply them wisely,
we can become a great uniting force
in times when we're most needed.
Okay, so that's what's been going on
in the wider world of things.
Now give me a minute or two to talk about
what's happening as far as I'm concerned
and what's going on at scoutmastercgcom.
First of all, I've been touched and very thankful
for all of those of you gotten in touch with me
over the summer to ask,
basically, are you okay?
What's going on
Well? first, everything's good,
Everything's great.
In June I decided I was going to take a break.
We were getting ready to head to Kondersteg,
and then I found excuses,
as the summer went by, to keep extending the break.
and now here we are in September.
Well, forgive me for that,
but it's been very refreshing
and I'm ready to get back to podcasting on a regular basis.
I don't know at this point
if it will be like I'm going back
to doing a weekly podcast,
and here's why
I have a couple of non-scout projects
I've been pursuing over the past year
that are demanding more of my attention,
and I'm going to continue working on them
and at some point maybe I'll tell you more about these,
but right now let me just leave that there.
Second, this is podcast number 352
and frankly, I'm running out of new things
to say that I believe are useful to you
every single week.
I mean, if you look at the whole back catalog of podcasts,
it's like a singer singing covers
of the same songs over and over again,
And what's great about that
is that that means that scouting
is really blissfully simple
and there's just so much
anybody can say about it
before they start repeating themselves.
What I really do enjoy
is the dialogue that we have,
and I'm happy to answer the same questions
over and over again.
So answering email questions will be continued
to be one of my favorite things to do
and a feature in future podcasts.
I think I mentioned it in past podcasts,
but I've also been working
on a redesign
of scoutmastercgcom,
which is a pretty huge project in itself
and demands a lot of time,
and the idea of the redesign
is to make what's there
more accessible.
Right now, it's hard to find
specific information about a given subject
or question in
over 350 podcasts
and 1600 blog posts
that I've created over the past 10 or 12 years.
So the redesign
is more than just updating the graphics
and everything. It's adding functionality
that will make things
easier to find
and adding a way for you
to make your own collection of information
kind of a personalized resource center
so you can actually access
and use the information at scoutmastercgcom
when you need it
and you don't have to go searching around,
because I get one of the regular emails
I get is: you know, I remember
you talked about or wrote about this thing
and I saw it at one point
and I can't find it now.
So I'm working on that.
this is a long
and costly process. It's taken a lot
longer than I thought it would take.
so bear with me because I think the end result
will be worth the wait.
So I know that maybe some of what
I've had to say about this is a little fuzzy
and unspecific and I wish I could have
more distinct plans, but I tend to
follow inspirations better and I do plans.
It's not the best way to be,
is it?
But it's basically
the way that I am
and I've found in the past that fighting that
is not really
very high performing for me,
so bear with me a little bit there.
that is catching up with you
and I'm gonna sign off for this episode,
but I'll be back
with our more familiar format soon.
I have a backlog of things to do
as far as the podcast is concerned:
lots of email questions to answer,
people to thank and really terrible
jokes to share with you.
I want to thank you once again for your
continued concern and listenership
and your financial support of
scoutmasterscgcom.
I really do appreciate your listening
in and getting to talk to you.
Stay in touch. I'm always at Clark
at scoutmasterscgcom,
and you can find me on Twitter and Facebook too.
Sir Robert, are you still there?
Good luck to you
and good camping
away. thank you, sir
you.